regarding bringing meritocracy into the
economy because like i was saying at the
beginning of the show jordan peterson
mentions you see it throughout his
throughout culture except in economy
because
ultimately wealthy people transfer
wealth to kids that aren't necessarily
intelligent or valuable but they're
super i think they're valuable yeah
valuable to society is what i mean
they're more of a drain than a plus but
what i i think we can do
is create a system where everyone can
have their own cryptocurrency i've
talked about this before and then
you can if you want to like subscribe to
my channel for 10 bucks a month cool but
if you want to pay me an ian coin i'll
give you a 10 discount so i generate
desire for my token and so we've created
almost like a meritocratic economy where
there's all these different currencies
and the the valuable ones are the ones
that give you the most utility right
right maybe
yeah yeah i mean i think crypto is
interesting um there was a huge crypto
revolution 2017 2018. everybody thought
all of their cryptocurrencies were gonna
go and be great but actually pareto rule
only one or two of them really ended up
skyrocketing it was bitcoin and ethereum
yeah but if you bought dogecoin
back when it came out
man you got rich there's like one dude
as a millionaire now of dogecoin i'm not
too worried about the actual dollar
value because in a system like that
there would be no like
central currency that everything is like
valued at it would just they would all
have value right based on the individual
well this i mean the reason why we have
a single currency money economy is to
eat to facilitate transactions just to
make it a lot easier
wouldn't it be easier for the world if
everyone had a one world currency
yeah that sounds like globalization yeah
why wouldn't it happen look at bitcoin
bitcoins used by everybody around the
world it's true so i don't know if
bitcoin will ever be hard currency but
we're certainly moving towards a future
where some crypto will be and maybe
that's kind of the point maybe the
titanic hit that 2008 when did bitcoin
come out ian 2008 2009 2009 right wasn't
it yeah yeah so somebody saw it was like
we need we need i mean look i'm not
saying conspiracy i'm saying the crisis
happens and this satoshi dude or whoever
whether it's a multiple people or not
was like that's a problem we need sound
currency
bitcoin boom
so now what happens it's just domino's
falling over man we start seeing
economic crisis economic collapse the
government is full of a bunch of benny
hill type stooge cops running around
with their holding their hats
frantically trying to figure out what's
going on and it's all melting down and
then in the end what happens everybody
in the world uses one thing bitcoin
crypto we're positioned now is the
united states where we have the power
it's kind of like george washington when
he was president he had the power they
wanted him to become a king do you want
the united states to stay the power but
like we have a responsibility just as
washington did to give that power away
to step down
and i think
now we're in the position to create a
world economy that with all these
different types of currencies that
intermingle and enter intercorrelate
yeah you know what man i i would love
for there to be
some kind of
system
global system
that
defends freedom protects uh sovereign
borders but still allows us to avoid war
and function in a unified manner in a
certain sense wait hold on
global system that protects freedom
what what kind how could a system which
is by nature organized and therefore has
to suppress some freedom or to gain
organization also protect freedom like a
bill of rights
a system based around a core of
ideologies that says
in order to violate a person's rights
they're much there must be due process
so we have organized a system in the us
not perfect but pretty good now there's
a lot of places in the world that don't
have that i'm not suggesting we go with
force and kick their doors in and then
staple constitutions to their walls but
it would be awesome if whatever ends up
happening with mass communications we
don't end up with a chinese communist
style overarching global authority we
end up with a classically liberal we
respect if you live in the united states
then you are allowed to set the laws of
the united states however no war
international agreements on not having
war not stealing resources you know
there's got to be something um
i'll tell you this there's that famous
quote that i think it was um
one of the rothschilds i'm not entirely
sure you would probably know where he
said
that it's not it's not uh it's not that
what do you say globalization will
happen whether anybody wants it to or
not or something like that and a lot of
people i know a lot of libertarians and
caps think he was you know twirling his
mustache going
globalization what happened when in
reality he was saying like the way the
world is going with communications and
trade we will eventually have a one
world government
the the goal i suppose is
the united states and those who live in
it should be able to have their rights
respected within their own borders they
should have their constitutional
freedoms and rights they shouldn't be
banned or censored or shut down
but there could be international
agreements on
what happens in the event of conflict of
war of territorial disputes so we can
get to that point we can't have a system
we already do have a system by which we
have an international currency it's
called visa and mastercard i can go to
any country in the world my car and
swipe and buy what i want it's so easy
the swift payment system that's the
global swift payment system because i'll
tell you man i've been watching a lot of
stargate sg-1 and you know one of the
biggest problems is that was and i'm not
talking about the fiction of the show
i'm talking about the writers perceive
when they're making the show right is
that when they encounter other worlds
and try to negotiate they say you can't
negotiate on the behalf of your people
you like if we give you weapons or
utility you'll go to war and you'll
destroy yourselves
so we need to have some kind of
we need to we need to have a way to
prevent world war iii or whatever now of
course there are powerful global
interests elites who
desperately want a one world authority
the only problem is they're crackpot
authoritarians who would burn your life
to the ground and sac and they don't
they don't they don't care about you as
an individual they care about the
numbers the utilitarianism that's a
nightmarish world to live that's what
the chinese communist party does so i'm
saying we don't want that okay but let
me give you a different perspective you
know our founding fathers were
authoritarians
because we're authoritarians well this
here this is what i mean i mean that we
gave them authoritarian power to write
our constitution
like at one point in time in the us
history we had an authoritarian
government because those people
were the ones who eventually came
together and then they created the
constitutional system that now protects
freedom but in order to do that we had
to trust them with the ability to
to make a constitution and a bill of
rights and then to actually execute on
that at least for the first people but
they didn't just take they just write a
constitution and staple it to a wall and
say this is what you have to deal with
it was actually extremely difficult in
order to actually get the constitution
they were going to states and
negotiating and the states were like bug
off we don't care we don't want this and
it was actually very very difficult and
took i think over like 15 or 20 years to
finally get states to actually vote for
and sign on to the constitutional system
it did it did but we still
trusted them to make the to make the
initial creative effort now we had the
ability to to provide a backlash against
that but again you know we had george
washington could have been king
he could have been a president so he had
to have the he had to actually step down
and say okay i'm not actually going to
do that other people you know that just
shows we didn't have the authoritarian
rule right and and that system was still
being developed at that time and there
were people who exercised sort of
authoritarian influence like in marbury
versus madison judicial branch was not
granted the ability for judicial review
at the time they gave themselves the
ability for judicial review and marbury
versus madison so they kind of had a
little bit of a
we're going to get some power nobody
gave them the ability to do that but
they did so but is that is that is are
some instances of of authority being
exercised in bad ways indicative of the
entire system being authoritarian at
some point
i would say yes you have totalitarian
authoritarians which are very dangerous
we're like the author of the the
constitution is the authoritarian i mean
it's the exact same word authoritarian
yeah that's the root of the word
authoritarianism author and that's right
is a system defined by an authority that
can that commands on down versus liberty
a liberty based system a weaker
centralized power structure i think
there's never uh it's never all or none
you always have aspects of authority
within any given system right a family
unit a government a democratic if you go
all the way to the top of the political
compass to authoritarian you've got a
guy who's beating the peasants to death
and holding people at gunpoint to steal
their stuff
authoritarian if you go that's that's
that's the epitome of authoritarian if
you go all the way to the bottom you get
anarchy and it's where either you have
free trade anarchy where it's you know
and caps or you have anarcho-syndicalism
or communism where people are sitting
around and basking in the glories of
their labor which is utopian to be
complicated it's like a lack of
authority or a tribe these these wait
right anarchy means without authority so
if you go all the way to the bottom with
anarchy you can literally have a small
tribe of people who agree to share
things and don't really ever think about
money or you can have free market
capitalists that are just like hey the
market dictates so just because somebody
says i should have the ability to like
you know there's somebody who says i'm
writing this constitution and this is
what i think we should do doesn't mean
the system is authoritarian they're like
so
we can either uh
it's it's it's it's a gradient okay you
could be 60 libertarian with 40
authoritarian you can be you know any
any number well you know what thomas
hobbes says about that what does he say
i mean he says
he says the function of a government is
to hold people at gunpoint they have the
the function of government has the power
to hold somebody at gunpoint and demand
things from them you know that he said
even
basically even we have this he would say
you know we have this veneer of
liberalism right now where we give the
people the illusion the ability that
they have you know rights and sincere
voting power but really
you know who has the ability to coerce
you it's the government yeah it's it's
true but
so in that sense it's a threat just
because there are rules doesn't mean
we're an authoritarian government
because the one thing about the united
states is and this is a lesson
conservative should have learned a while
ago you're allowed to speak for the most
part
and use that ability to build culture
now there are confines in the overton
window
but because many people on the right
weren't actively building culture they
were chasing after it constantly
defending from what the left wanted the
left owns the narrative in the united
states we we have an authoritarian
culture that is taking over we still
have some libertarian aspects within it
and if we don't stop the authoritarian
encroachment it goes into government
which it is with what joe biden is doing
and this this is something i was talking
about four or five years ago
and and now here we are where we're
dangerously close to the government
absorbing authoritarian cultural aspects
and the people who oppose it being too
fractured to do anything about it what i
mean to say is for the longest time the
united states was not authoritarian in
that you could absolutely have your you
know crackpot free speech group going
around saying crazy things and even have
the aclu defend you as you march through
skokie illinois with saying saying
horribly and anti-semitic things but
that was because we authoritatively
decided you could do that by saying if
you're gonna stop them from doing that
we're gonna keep we're gonna arrest you
so they have freedom that's a thought
that's the authoritarian aspect of
argument you misunderstand what
authoritarian means
right yeah a cop who says i can't arrest
a guy for speaking as an authoritarian a
guy a cop who says i can arrest you if
you try to physically harm that person
is still not an authoritarian oh i think
they are authoritarian i mean police by
nature are authoritarian they are the
author of law yeah they're at least the
arm of the author they're an authority i
think you misunderstand authoritarian
which is a government system of a
top-down authority and centralized i
would i would argue that saying that a
government
saying the big a authoritarian is a
misnomer that you really can't say again
you're just kidding
there's always guardian it's always a
gradient of authority within a
government so you're confusing the word
authority with authoritarian
so so the police are constrained by the
public in many many ways now the cops
cops can do bad things they can they can
seize your guns and smart with a smile
on their face when they do it they will
kick grandma in the teeth to enforce
these lockdowns so we're entering that
period that's what i'm saying we are
entering an authoritarian government
because the it starts with the culture
and moves in and nothing was going to
stop it however oh we had civil rights
where they and they won they integrated
the schools with authoritarianism they
went in with guns in their arms and said
we're now this sits this school is now
integrated but that wasn't because a
king or a centralized command structure
made it so it was the president
it was yes and it was because of mandate
from the public true yeah we are our own
author in that system so you're
confusing authoritarian
well maybe maybe it's the totalitarian
which is the extreme authoritarianism is
actually totalitarianism if you've got a
house with 10 people in it and six
people demand pepperoni you know on
their pizza and four demand uh
pineapple
is it authoritarian when the six people
are like were ordering pepperoni
no it's it's a democratic vote now
democracy can be tyranny tyranny of the
majority but there's a big difference
between a centralized hierarchical
command structure of authority that
dictates everyone has to do something
and no one can do anything about it and
a group of people coming out voicing
their opinion and the system changing in
response to the will right people when
you have one person issuing the
authority it's very dangerous but when
you have a group able to do it it's
called democracy so so to to clarify too
there can be cult authoritarianism for
sure everybody marching to dogma and
just reacting in a certain way and
that's black lives matter and and
critical race theory and critical race
applied principles but when that goes
into government you end up with
dictatorial presidents
screaming the top of their lungs
threatening people and using those
powers against their perceived enemies
and that's when your government becomes
authoritarian
okay it's interesting
let's i want to go back to your pizza
example for a second i think it's
interesting so the group decides
uh
so six people they're ten people six
people designed pepperoni four people
decide on pineapple but
someone still has to make the call to
dominoes
and say okay we're getting pepperoni
pizza yep now that person may say i have
the mandate to call dominoes
because
we have the majority who said they want
pepperoni so i'm going to call pepperoni
but what if somebody on the pineapple
side was like well no you don't have the
mandate because we want to make it
unanimous you're like well no i think
it's majority rule and then at that
point it's a it's actually
i could see it be the person
who is who calls the pepperoni is just
actually just asserting his power over
ten people did you agree to the rules
i don't know did they yes i mean we've
long had a structure in place of like
here's how we'll have the vote here here
good certainly shake hands these are the
rules for the game in terms of how we
make decisions then four people start
screaming it's not fair it's not fair
it's what you get with 2016. they all
agreed to the rules of the election and
then screamed all these horrible things
about about you know donald trump when
it came to the 2020 election a bunch of
republicans and democrats started
changing voter rules in many states
which resulted in a major lawsuit by
texas which is very very different which
is i can understand why many of the
trump supporters are angry about it
among other things so the issue is if
you and i agree we're going to arm
wrestle and the winner gets to choose
what topping we put on our pizza and you
lose you can't then claim well you you
don't have the mandate that's
authoritarian i'm like bro we agree to
this right we agreed to a sorting
mechanism by which we decide how things
are made just because we have to make
hard decisions and someone has to be the
one to do it doesn't mean that it's an
authoritarian system if if if black
lives matter gains power because of
their cult ideology they will have the
ability to enforce this because they
have a bunch of zealots who go around
smashing windows and beating people but
there will be one person who exercises
the authority and dictates to their cult
to go and take action
then the will of the people doesn't
matter anymore so you look at cuba most
people did not want communism they did
not want a dictatorship but they were
tricked and manipulated and the
revolutionary forces of castro had the
ability to take whatever they wanted
people resisted there was no agreement
to that that was authoritarian
manny no one voted for him to do this
well actually i don't know exactly if
maybe they had a faux vote but i'm
pretty sure the elections never came
that's what jose was saying the
constitution never came the election
never came and before we knew it castro
was just the dictator who controlled
everything
that's where we're going thanks to
critical race theory and the elimination
of meritocracy the idea is get you cut
off the tall grass you take away
anyone's ability to challenge you and
you mandate things based on seemingly
random characteristics and then that's
another way that's probably the the one
of the surefire ways towards
authoritarianism with a meritocratic
system you it's it's not as easy to have
authoritarianism but you can right
with americredic system you can get
let's let's just call it a a free market
system
over time monopolies form power develops
and you get the east india trading
company no regulation the wealthiest
most powerful company that ever existed
and they can do what they want set up
cities enslave people attack people
with
central centralization with leftist
ideology with things like critical race
theory you use ideology and you just
centralize authority immediately so
instead of taking a long amount of time
to earn your position they assert it by
force
right i mean this is this is the premise
of my book you know an inconvenient
minority so
you know critical race theorists you
know
they
they actually it's funny the way we talk
about critical race there is because you
need to realize that critical race
theorists use race as a marketing tool
they use race as a marketing tool to get
people of that race
to support them to value them to buy
their books to vote for them everything
like that um race is a marketing tool
that that's at this at this stage of of
things
um it was it's a marketing tool for for
the purpose of of eventual oppression
because if you can convince somebody
that their race
is what matters to you and race is a set
of characteristics that involves not
acting white or acting white or this
kind of thing then you can convince them
to do things based on things that they
wouldn't otherwise have chosen to do
because you've appealed to a racial
identity well there's another component
to the critical race theory stuff yeah
and it's it's the riots
that's their physical enforcement if you
don't agree with them they smash your
window so what do we see in places like
berkeley people in their windows they
put up black lives matter signs the
signs don't actually mean they support
black lives matter the signs actually
mean please don't hurt me
yeah i think i think that kenny is
making the extremely salient point that
at the end of the day the bottom line is
the question of who decides and this is
the issue of censorship who decides what
is misinformation who decides whether
joe biden should be taken off youtube
and joe biden mentioned this a little
while ago he's like it's not so much
about the votes as who counts the votes
that is the person who decides who's
going to be in power the person who
calls the shots thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you